hey guys I'm Erik Bosse and a lot of you
been asking about this new series on HBO
called Westworld you probably caught
some of those trippy promos that HBO has
been running before episodes of well
everything now that game of Thrones is
winding down with only two more shorter
seasons left HBO clearly wants a new
epic series to carry the torch and to
give viewers a new show with extreme
violence and so much pain in the
background but seriously I think
Westworld is going to be awesome so what
is it
Westworld is a show that takes place in
the near future with a western themed
amusement park filled with extremely
lifelike robots called hosts and for a
bargain of $40,000 a day you can live in
the lawless world of the old American
West ride horses shoot people have sex
with hookers talk about the deep
philosophical questions about the nature
of humanity you know real Carol boys
stuff and just like any sci-fi story
that deals with artificial intelligence
the robots prove that they cannot be
trusted now if this whole concept of a
futuristic theme park that becomes
unstable and kills all the guests sounds
a bit like Jurassic Park that's because
both Westworld
and Jurassic Park were the brain child's
brain children of the same guy
Michael Crichton he wrote and directed
the 1973 movie Westworld which the show
is loosely based on and Michael Crichton
loved stories where mankind's attempt to
play God blows up in our faces
creates dinosaurs God destroys dinosaurs
God creates a man man destroys guide
then creates dinosaurs now Westworld the
movie is definitely worth checking out
and that version of the story Westworld
is actually one of three sections of the
park along with medieval world and Roman
world now these were obviously inspired
by places like frontier land and fantasy
land in Disneyland and Disney World
second which opened just two years
before this movie came out so Michael
Crichton was clearly having some very
dark thoughts fall in mind for it's a
small world so in the 70's version of
West world Richard Benjamin and James
Brolin played Peter and John two buddies
looking for a vacation from Peters
marital problem so they head to West
world where they have a great time
shooting drinking gambling and robot
screwing that's until a robot disease
begins to cause all the robots to go
haywire and Yul Brynner plays the main
tagging is the gunslinger he's a creepy
murderous cowboy robot who spends half
the movie hunting peter down and he's
nearly impossible to destroy actually
think the gunslinger might have been an
inspiration for the terminator now in
the HBO version of Westworld these two
guests are now William and Logan played
by Jimmy Simpson and Ben barn and while
the show does look like it'll go deep
into Williams depression and need for an
escape it's really the broader world of
characters that seem to be getting the
spotlight this includes other
adaptations from the bill like the
engineer of the host Bernard Lowe played
by Jeffrey Wright and Edie Harris's
mysterious man in black it also includes
the loris a host Android feeling pangs
of consciousness that's played by Evan
Rachel Wood and of course Sir Anthony
Hopkins as dr. Robert Ford he's pretty
much the John Hammond of this nightmare
theme park wanted to show them something
that Washington managed I designed every
part of this base another quick detail
about the film Westworld the way you can
tell whether someone's a robot is by
looking at their hands the idea being
that the robot designers couldn't create
authentic human hands and that makes
sense because human hands are actually
one of the hardest things for artists to
sketch accurately we'll see if that
comes up in the show at all now the
movie is only about 88 minutes long and
we barely get to see West world in
action before everything starts going to
hell so just like Jurassic Park it's
more of the story of when this theme
park devolves into a nightmare but with
nothing close to the scale or production
quality Jurassic Park hat but it's the
concept that wess world is remembered
for and the creators of the HBO show
loved it so much they wanted to expand
it into this vast universe filled with
interesting characters something like
Game of Thrones or lost or any other
show that people obsess over 40 years
after the movie came out society has
been reshaped by the internet video
games virtual and augmented reality like
we've created secondary digital lives
for ourselves to escape into so how has
that sense of escapism changed who we
are
that's what West world is all about and
you may be thinking wait we already saw
what happens when modern filmmakers try
to expand the world of a Michael
Crichton classic but do not worry
because West world isn't just an attempt
to cash in and stretch out a franchise
there really isn't a franchise to cash
in on the original West world movie
barely made 10 million dollars this is
just a cool new show with an all-star
cast with Game of Thrones production
value and yes
violence and sex but there are a few key
things making this show unique that I'm
really excited about first Westworld
digs deep into the philosophy of its
concept the creators of this show are
Jonathan Nolan and his wife Lisa joy
Nolan you may know Jonathan Nolan from
co-writing the movies The Prestige and
interstellar with his brother
Christopher Nolan the Nolan's are
fascinated by characters whose
philosophies conflict with their
humanity so in the prestige it was
magicians whose perfectionism forced
them to sacrifice loving home lives and
in West world it's society's need for
escapism forcing us to sacrifice our
empathy for our fellow man or in this
case our empathy for our fellow
artificial man and critics are raving
over how thought-provoking the show is
the best science fiction is a reflection
of our current society and just like
Stanley Kubrick questioned the dangers
of artificial intelligence in his movie
2001 a Space Odyssey open the pod bay
doors go I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I
can't do that
West world is tackling big questions
like what makes us human and where do we
draw the line between a dehumanized
person with no moral code and a
humanized machine programmed with
morality in 2001 Kubrick visualized
those themes in the monolith that was
his recurring symbol for human
technology through the ages and in
Westworld Nolan appears to be using the
Vitruvian Man which is based on a famous
sketch by Leonardo da Vinci a lot of
people consider the Vitruvian Man to be
the first anatomically correct sketch of
the human body and it suggests humans
are the product of intelligent design
that obsession with the harmonic balance
of the human anatomy may be connected
with the idea of designing the hosts
hand just right so Kubrick used the
monolith to suggest man kinds of
technology and this vitruvian man seems
to be West world's symbol for mankind's
mastery over technology their pride as
they now consider themselves God now you
may have recognized that these are very
similar themes to the show Battlestar
Galactica which a lot of people have
been comparing it to both shows are deep
amazing remakes of kind of campy 70
sci-fi but there are two other classic
artificial intelligence movies at West
world looks like it's pulling from Blade
Runner and the recent movie that had
inspired ex machina these movies both
featured the Turing test in which a
human interacts with a computer seeking
signs of
real artificial intelligence and if you
look at this scene with dr. Ford and
Dolores it definitely has that same cold
creepy tone of those famous
questionnaire scenes and the fact that
Westworld wants to evoke those same
movies in particular is very promising
for the philosophical weight this show
will have moving on and do another thing
I'm excited about for Westworld the
sense of mystery another executive
producer on the show is JJ Abrams and
this guy has turned keeping us in the
dark into a high art form the
withholding information you know doing
that intentionally is much more engaging
it's why the first season of Lost was so
great Abrams knew just how to tease
little hints to keep us obsessed with
the central mystery of the show and so
what is the central mystery of West's
world
well the Nolan's and JJ Abrams are the
most secretive filmmakers in show
business they don't let anything leak
but judging from the first few episodes
that critics have been able to see West
world is going way deeper than the
simple sci-fi thought experiment that
movie was specifically is looking at the
possible nefarious motives behind the
park so there's this mysterious dello
score per ation there's a shadow group
that funds the park and looking at the
promotional website that HBO set up I'm
getting some major Dharma Initiative
vibes you might remember that as a
creepy organization from lost this also
reminds me of the Weiland corporation
site set up for the movie prometheus
which is written by Damon Lindelof of
course co-created lost with JJ Abrams
but probably the most obvious one is ed
Harris's character the man in black now
if he's stuck with loss through the
later seasons one of the more
interesting villains was this guy who
was also known as the man in black this
guy was an evil immortal figure who
manipulated people on the island to try
to escape
similarly this man in black is an
immortal host with kind of a cloudy
morality probing the outskirts of West
world in search of a maze to access the
parks inner sanctum now I personally
love the later seasons of lost and the
man in black was a big reason why I kind
of wish he was there from the beginning
but then again
spoiler alert I guess he technically was
in smoke form anyway I love that West
world has given us this big mysterious
character right out of the gate I think
we can all agree that loss at its best
was a really really fun ride I'm excited
for that kind of gripping storytelling
to come back
television and since I brought up a
character who's obsessed with mazes I
really should talk about the amazing
visuals of the show the look of this
world
I mentioned Stanley Kubrick earlier now
Jonathan Olin along with his brother
Chris are obsessed with Kubrick
specifically Kubrick's mastery of
creating elaborate intellectual mazes in
his films for example in the shining
the psychological maze that Jack is
trapped in manifests into a literal
labyrinth at the end of the movie with
himself becoming the Minotaur monster
the Nolan's have used this same
geometric maze imagery and movies like
Inception and interstellar and Jonathan
Nolan appears to be doing the same in
West world judging from these shots of
spiral staircases and of a mysterious
maze pattern in the table and in the
dirt so not only is Westworld Kubrick
Ian in the way it examines sci-fi themes
it's also Kubrick Ian's in its visual
design but also let's not forget West
world is a Western and there's just
something about westerns that captivates
American audiences the gorgeous
landscapes the period sets in costumes
whole lawless spirit of the world it's
also so reminiscent of the westerns of
John Ford and more recently the amazing
HBO series Deadwood actually wouldn't be
surprised if West's world is using some
of the same Deadwood sets and costumes
in this Western iconography fits really
well with the West world sci-fi concept
so why is that like a lot of times
movies will try to mix the natural world
with futuristic tech like in Wild Wild
West or Cowboys and Aliens and it just
feels off but West world doesn't fall
into that trap that's because it's
dueling settings are thematically linked
so we see westerns at their heart we're
really about simple life on the Prairie
and how technology often represented by
the railroad ended that way of life
technology replacing humanity that is
West world at its core so if you're
seeing sleek futuristic tech imagery
like something form ex machina or gritty
western imagery like in Deadwood it all
feels like one the matically connected
world and that is a big reason why
West's world could become the new HBO
series people obsess over and sure Game
of Thrones is still pretty much
dominating TV but once its watch is
ended keep an eye out for this show to
take over and I'm like Game of Thrones
West fool doesn't have these huge source
novels to pull storylines from it's just
a short movie from the 70s it's already
moving well beyond so we have no idea
where this story is headed that is super
exciting if you loved any of these
movies
TV shows that are referenced Jurassic
Park lost Battlestar Galactica Blade
Runner or the prestige or Deadwood
you're probably going to dig West world
so let me know what you think of the
show I'd love to do breakdowns of it but
really the show would have to take off
first so let's see what happens if you
like this video please like it and share
it with your friends and of course
subscribe to new rock stars that's one
way you can help grow this channel
another way is to contribute to us on
patreon a huge thank you to all of our
current patrons on patreon you guys are
amazing you're a big reason why we're
able to get videos out you can also
follow new rock stars on Twitter at new
rock stars for information about when
our videos are coming out or you can
follow me on twitter at EA Voss with any
thoughts or theories or questions or
things that you love about Westworld
alright guys that's all I got thanks for
watching bye
[Music]